so so my name is James Powell I'm giving
the third unofficial keynote of pi data
London I'm really excited to be here I
think the conference has turned out to
be fantastic so far I'd like to
introduce myself briefly then we'll jump
into generators I know that the other
talks to this talk is listed as advanced
and the other talk was acid as novice
the material that i have prepared for
you actually goes from novice to
advanced so i may spend a little bit of
time towards a novice side just to see
if i can cover as much as possible so as
ian said these are all the meetup groups
in the world and if we scroll down we
can see there's a lot of really big ones
in Silicon Valley that are general
interest and if we scroll down the
number five here we see the first Python
specific meetup group on this page NYC
Python 4509 members this is our meetup
group you can see there's my dopey photo
in there I think I'm actually wearing
this suit in that photo it is one of the
it is something that I am probably one
of the things I'm most proud of that I
do in the community which is run this
meetup group you can see our next event
is actually at pivotal i'll be giving a
sea python workshop very similar to the
talk that I gave on Friday this is just
an amazing group of people the amount of
energy the amount of excitement towards
Python towards Big Data towards web
programming is just absolutely it
impresses me every single time
additionally i am running a conference
in new york city on the fourteenth of
march called for python quads a couple
of speakers from today will be there it
is a conference that is a little bit
more specifically targeting the
intersection of big data finance and
python so a couple of speakers i'll be
speaking we have somebody from ponto
peon dr. hill pitch will be speaking
about derivative analytics and the
keynote will be given by curette singh
who has twice over developed the two
largest python systems in industry that
nobody seems to know about one at JP
Morgan are one a bank of america so some
very very exciting talks i'm also i have
a blog here i have an updater in a very
long time but if you want to go into any
wild wacky coding you know i have some
so the domain that i got for it was
don't use this code calm and i put the
blog on seriously don't use this code
calm I thought that was great one of the
other things that I do is I
hope this one is the one I want to go
first so I help run the PI data
conference series i'm one of the
co-organizers so what that allows me to
do is it allows me to tweet and then to
retweet myself from the stage so I think
if I go to this one here I'll actually
be able to retweet myself immediately
and it is said that power corrupts and
that absolute power corrupts absolutely
so I don't know if I should tweet this
or not I thought that would be quite
humorous but you can see that when you
have access to the twitter feed for pi
data you can do quite a bit of damage so
I don't know maybe I'll just delete it
after this talk tweet so this is what
this is one of the things I do so let's
get started with generators so just as a
show of hands in the negative who looks
at this piece of code and doesn't know
what it does so who's clueless when they
see what this does just so I can
calibrate where I want to go so
everybody knows what this does great who
looks at this piece of code and doesn't
know what it does okay so everybody
knows what generator is fantastic who
looks at this piece of code and has no
idea what's going on okay so Kohler
teens people are a little bit a little
bit soft on who looks at this piece of
code and doesn't know what's going on so
generator expressions and then finally
who looks at this piece of code and
doesn't know what's going on so don't
lie because nobody knows what's going on
in this piece of code this is wild wild
stuff okay great so the notes for this
are in an I Python notebook it'll be
posted along with the other slides I
have this laid out I'm going to spend a
little bit more time towards the
beginning of these notes just so that I
can cover the introductory details of
what a generator is so again here are
some of my details you can email me at
James that don't use this code calm you
can follow me on twitter at don't use
this code or python quants you can read
my blog seriously don't use code calm or
you can attend NYC Python or the
conference that's being run on the
fourteenth of March so I like to look at
generators and functions from a formal
perspective by formal perspective I mean
the form of them because you can see in
the previous example that my generator
and my function look very similar and
the only difference is from from first
glance the only difference is where
there was a return there's now a yield
so starting with that this is just a
very typical function and throughout the
notes throughout this first section this
is just about the standard function that
I'll use all it does is it returns two
values X plus 1 and X plus 2 and you can
see that I test it and you can see the
example usage of it I call the function
with this parentheses and it returns an
answer nothing too fancy and then we can
see that a generator formally is just
the same thing as this function except
instead of a return statement I have a
yield statement and in the example usage
instead of calling it with parenthesis i
call it with parentheses to instantiate
the generator instance and then i
iterate through it in order to get the
values so in the first case i'm getting
the values immediately when i when i
when i call it with these parentheses
and in the second case i have to iterate
through the resultant object in order to
get the actual result and you can see
that a generator expression is very
similar to a generator except instead of
having this extra step of instantiating
the expression we essentially in line
the generator instance so nothing too
fancy here i think though if we step a
little bit one level higher we can see
that in python there are these
fundamental protocols so I view Python
as a collection of ad hoc fundamental
protocols the two most fundamental of
which are call ability and inter ability
so let's talk about it er ability or
let's talk about call ability first
actually so call a bulls in Python are
just a generalization of function and we
know that there are these things that
sit at our code and we can put
parenthesis after them and a result
comes out one example of them is a
function but another example is a class
you put parenthesis after the name of
the class and you get a class instance
you there's also generator objects
themselves you put parenthesis after
that and you get a generator instance
there's also see functions which under
the hood look very very different than
regular Python functions but you put
parenthesis after that and you get a
result and we can see that part of part
of what Python allows us to do it allows
us to look very abstractly at what's
going on so in this case we have a
callable and it's just some random
object and it implements underscore call
underscore
and gives a result and there's nothing
too fancy here and we could do this in
order to implement any sort of abstract
behavior that we want under this
protocol of probability nothing nothing
very interesting at all similarly itter
ability is one of these abstract
protocols that we have so there are a
lot of different things in Python that
we can iterate over we can iterate over
lists but in the same sense we can
implement in it itter and next and we
can create a custom iterable object and
all it is is an object that has some
protocol some code that we interact with
in a very defined fashion and we have a
use we have a usage site right here and
it D sugars into the resulting of a
value where we iterate through a set of
computations now this is to motivate
what a generator really is because if
you look in the C Python code itself
you'll see that both functions and
generators share an enormous amount of
code in fact when you pull out a value
from a generator you really go through
the same eval frame xcode that you would
if you call a function and behind the
scenes actually a generator is really
just a function with a special flag set
so that the first time you call it you
get a code object paired with a frame
object that just kind of lingers around
or to put another way in a function in
the C code when you hit return you clean
up all of the local state that you've
generated and your turn of value in a
generator when you hit a yield statement
you actually leave you literally leave
everything around and then for you to
reinvigorate max you'll actually see
quite literally this is the case when
you return you jump to the bottom of the
function when you yield you jump past
the cleanup and continue and so the code
is actually very simple in this case
what a generator really is is just some
iteration with some notion of state and
this can be related to things like
delayed computations to laziness but in
its essence all it is is something that
you can iterate over in this formal in
this formal mode of 4x and xs and it
remembers where it was and so here we
have an example of some abstract
iterable that just implements this
protocol we have the ability to get the
next element and we know where we last
work and if we generalize this to
computations we can think that a
generator is just
over something where the things were
iterating over our computations and our
state is what was the last computation
that we actually compute so co routines
and what our co routines co routines if
you go to Wikipedia you can see that
wikipedia says that a co routine is a
generalization of a subroutine and what
they mean is this in our first formal
example we saw that a function has one
entry point and essentially one exit
point you call a function with some
input parameters some code runs and it
returns and it eagerly gives you the
result of some computation so f of X in
the first example gives you X plus 1 and
X plus 2 a co routine is a
generalization of this where you have
multiple entry and multiple exit points
namely you can run a block of executed
code and it pauses and you're able to
re-enter that executed code and return
some more values and leave that state
intact re-enter that return some more
values and leave that state intact and
so in Python very formally a co routine
gives you a co routine is implemented by
the addition of three additional methods
namely throw send and close so i'll go
over this very briefly and then we can
get into the meat of why do i do this so
here we have our very standard generator
example we take one input X and we
return we first yield x plus one and
then we yield X plus 2 in order to get
these values out we have to iterate so
unlike the function where the code runs
to completion on invocation the
generator only returns values as you ask
for them and in order to make this a co
routine we just see that there's a next
method so in Python 2 it's called next
in Python 3 it's called underscore next
and all this is is a is our way to
interact with this protocol of getting
the next computation or the next value
out so just like in the for loop we can
take we can take our for looping week
and eat sugar it into a while loop that
just calls next until we've exhausted
the computations next isn't anything
terribly interesting and it's part of
the basic generator protocol however
throw clothes and send or what we're
talking about when we talk about car
routines so you can think that
if our generator is yielding chunks of a
computation at some point we may want to
raise an exception because in regular
code we have some desire to raise the
computation and throw is just one way
that we can raise an exception inside of
this competition it's not terribly
useful you don't see it use that often
outside of large libraries that use
generators quite extensively like
twisted or something like that it's not
something that we run into very often
similarly closes our way to take a
suspended computation and close to say
clean up you're done we're never going
to get another computation out the meat
of this all is I don't know why I put it
last but the meat of this all is set so
in a function you have one chance to get
input in and you have one chance to get
out put out and you may have in the
actual coding many return statements but
if you think about it input comes in and
you return it one of those statements
and the computation it's completed in a
generator what you can do is you can put
in put in when you invoke the generator
and then at each stage you can add
additional inputs in and get additional
outputs out and you can actually relate
those those partial inputs the partial
outputs so here we have a generator
that's very simple all it does is it
takes an input value and it yields at
input value plus one and then it and it
also yields the state of this internal
variable Y and then it takes in some
additional input stores it to Y and then
runs again so if we look at the running
of this format here it's not that great
but we put in ten first and we grab the
next value so we have 11 and none
because why was set to none and then in
the next step we can actually send a
value back into the generator and inside
this computation here we can make use of
that value so you can see G send ABC and
we get 12x plus 2 and ABC and what we
could do here is we could actually do
something like that and we can actually
do we could actually perform some
additional computation on some
additional input so in this sense a co
routine is merely a function where you
have the ability to suspend it and then
add more inputs you have a
generalization of a function or a
subroutine which only takes input once
and returns output once now there's one
note and
is very important to what happens in the
rest of the slides which is pumping and
priming and this is kind of a wart of
how generators are expressed in Python
if you look at a large library that uses
generators extensively something like
twisted you'll see somewhere along the
line somebody's written a decorator
called pump or prime there a lot of
different names but it has to do with
when you put the when you can get inputs
into the generator so here's our very
simple generator and you can see that
we've tried to put a value into it and
we get this nasty and very strange error
called can't send none on value to
adjust start a generator the problem is
this when we want to put input into the
generator we have the ability to start
this generator instance with some value
in the form of parameters at the top
generator X right right here and then as
we want to add additional inputs in we
have to think when are we actually able
to inject them into the generator we
can't do it what what happens in this
code is will run all the byte codes from
here down to the first yield and will
result in this value there's no way for
us to put a value into the generator
before this first yield statement and as
a consequence you can't send a value
into a generator or send a value into a
co routine before that first yield
statement and it's very hard to really
wrap your head around this and it
results in weird errors like this error
below but just as a note whenever you're
looking at a large code base that uses
generators or users co routines you'll
probably see something called pump or
prime and it's trying to avoid this
ugliness of syntax we're getting that
first input into the co routine is just
not possible given the syntax and the
form of generators that we have now I
want to give a little aside about
itertools this is my out of my 23 most
favorite libraries in Python this is
probably number two I'm you know
actually people believe that I have 23
most favorite libraries in Python as a
sideout I'll tell you that I don't have
any cards left but I have some business
cards for NYC Python
and on the back I put different import
statements I went through all the code
that I wrote my little scratch folder
and I want and I put all the import
statements that I used most commonly
from this import disk from ctypes import
CD el CD ll no sorry from C types in PI
object from itertools import chain and I
found all my most favorite imports I had
six of these and I sent this to a friend
of mine who is on the co-organizers list
but wasn't very technical and I said
what do you think of these slides and he
said what's that weird program code on
the back and I said actually each one of
these has an exciting story to go behind
it and I wrote out a very long email
with you know a 10 minute story for each
one of those inputs and his response was
I wish there existed in some language a
word that meant I immediately regret
asking this question so I'll tell you
about it er tools which is one of my
favorite libraries because it's very
relevant to generators and it's very
relevant to the use of generators in
Python one reason that I think
generators among all the features in
Python deserves a talk by itself is that
if you look at the transition from
Python to the Python 3 you can see that
the focus on this fundamental protocol
of adorability is one of the
distinguishing factors of Python 3
namely in a very superficial level
things like map and filter have been
turned into these a lazy map what what
in Python 2 is called i'm a poor i
filter and you can see that this focus
of iterable attias a fundamental
protocol has taken center stage and
python 3 and itertools is one of our
most useful libraries for interacting
with intervals whether they be
generators or just classic literals so
itertools is a collection of
generalizations it's a collection of
helpers it's a correction of algorithms
and you can see throughout these notes
and throughout my code it is one of the
most useful libraries that I have and it
allows us to solve a lot of problems in
a very robust and very generic fashion
so when I talk about generalizations one
of the examples is I slice so we know
that standard lists can be sliced we
have this syntax to get elements from
one to five not including number five
out of the list and here we have a
formulation of a Fibonacci sequence as a
and we have the ability to slice through
this as well we can't use this bracket 1
colon 5 syntax to slice into it but it
or tools gives us something called I
slice and I slice is a way that we can
slice into something without having to
know what it is so I size could allow us
to slice through a list a dictionary a
tuple or a generator it's a
generalization of a very standard
mechanism it's similarly in Python 2 we
have I zip I map I filter we have these
generalizations of ways to look at these
iterable so they're having to know
anything about their internal their
internal details their implementation
details similarly itertools contains a
lot of helpers so we know that we can
append lists and I'm sure that almost
all of you have at some point run into
some code that added one list to another
list and it turns out that when people
were calling this code or somewhere in
the function it adds one list another
list and when people are calling the
function that does this they
accidentally passed in at uppal and I
got a really nasty error saying you
can't add a list to a temple I know I've
run into this a couple of times and you
could think that chaining two things
together is a very natural thing it
doesn't matter what a is it doesn't
matter what B is you may just want to
chain them together without having to
know that this is a list and this is a
temple and chain is one of these helpers
it is a way that we can take any sort of
abstract iterable and concatenate them
together without having to know anything
about how they how they work internally
all chained does is it gives you a
wrapped iterable and it goes through all
the values of the first one and then all
the values of x1 tends to be very very
very useful it is probably my third most
favorite function in Python chain that
from iterable and so you can see that
similarly there's t-there's repeat their
cycle there's a lot of these very nice
helpless itertools is a fantastic
libraries one of the best parts of the
standard library and similarly in the
standard library we have these
algorithms so here we have an infinite
sequence of Fibonacci numbers so this
will just this is a generator and it
just continuously generate numbers from
the Fibonacci sequence and that's not
terribly useful for us because if we try
and stick it into a list will run out of
memory very quickly but we might want to
do is you might want to take certain
elements of them and for and itertools
includes function called take Wow
and take while allows us to give it a
predicate and just take elements from
this iterable until this predicate is no
longer met so here we take all the
elements from the Fibonacci sequence
where that element is less than 50
similarly itertools includes drop while
it includes product combinations
permutations all of these ways that we
can take our sequences or and combine
them and perform different very standard
permutation on them so given that and
given our knowledge of what I generator
very roughly is there's a question of
why we want to use it what's what's the
purpose what's the what's the goal
behind this why would we want to apply
the sophistication to our programs and I
think that this can be answered in two
parts and the the first the first answer
to this question I find is usually
something about efficiency and I don't
think that it's the most compelling
answer but it is the most common answer
so let's think for a second about what a
function is a function eagerly computes
some sequence of computations so it has
one entry point and one exit point and
from entry to exit it does the entire
computation and a generator instead
gives you the ability to segment that
computation to demarcate that
computation into chunks and it'll come
it'll do each one of these pieces only
as you asked for that computation so
very naturally I think what we can get
from this is an idea that generators
give us memory efficiency in this sense
this guy pairwise is something that pops
up in my code all the time namely for
some reason I have some set of data in a
stream and I want to look at windowed
pairs of it so if I had numbers from one
to ten I'd want to look at 1 2 2 3 3 4
and so on I want to be able to compare
the current piece of data to the next
piece of data or to the previous piece
of data a very simple example of this is
some sort of window to average if I
wanted to take the average of every
three elements from a stream that would
just be paralyzed with a size of three
here I have it implemented in our very
standard fashion as a function and you
can see that it creates a temporary
variable called pairings and it will
take the first element and
the second element and stick it into
pairings in the second element third
elements and so forth and so on and if I
run this on a list of numbers from 0 to
9 this is the output and it's pretty
straightforward but you can think what
if I run it on elements from 0 to a
million this function by virtue of
having to do the entire computation at
once is probably going to run out of
memory or probably stress the memory
that I have available and in the case
that I'm doing something like a windowed
average I don't need the entire
computation i only need each one of the
windows at any one point in time
generators give us the ability to look
at only the part of the computation that
we need immediately so here I have
pairwise rewritten as a generator and
you can see that the codes a lot simpler
I'm no I no longer have to deal with
this temporary variable to actually
little bit shorter a little bit clearer
and here it still gives me the elements
from 0 to 9 paired up but if I were to
do this and actually try and prepare
wise of X range 1 million it'll give me
a result and the result will give me is
this deferred computation here and as I
want each of these elements I can pull
them out I can process them but I won't
have to allocate memory equal to the
entire size of this list this is
something that's very very powerful it
allows us to construct our computation
is a set of independent units that work
on streams where each one of them
doesn't have to run to completion but
can can iteratively look at one part of
the computation and then pass it down
the stream additionally and this is one
reason to look at editor tools first is
itertools allows us to create things
like NY sore pairwise very nicely very
succinctly very robustly and very
quickly so in later parts of these notes
i'll be using this formulation of NYS
which is just a combination of pieces
from itertools it looks really scary but
it's actually very simple this is
something that I can type by memory
because I've typed it so many times
essentially all we do is we take the
stream we copy it three times we
enumerate each one of those copies and
then we stagger them so we take from 0
to 9
and we stagger the next one from one to
nine and the next one from two to nine
and then across we zip them together so
this is just a generalization of this
pair wise and you can see that we can
write it as a formulation using these
fundamental building blocks from
itertools very very tersely and very
efficiently so we can see very easily
why why we want to motivate the use of
generators by virtue of not having to
complete the entire computation we can
look at only subsets of the computation
and those subsets only require memory
equal to the window that we need so in
the case of for example pairwise we only
need memory storage for the two values
that we're looking at right now and if
this pairwise were being used for a
rolling average we only need memory
equal to the number of elements that we
have in that window as opposed to
needing memory for the entire sequence
so we have great gains memory wise
there's a question of time efficiency
and this is a very tricky one to answer
so I'll give you one example of
something that I find to be fairly
unconvincing but still nevertheless is
somewhat interesting here I have some
C++ code that I wrote now I would run in
C++ in a very long time so this isn't
very good C++ code but all it does is it
implements this pair wise with a window
of three so so for the numbers from 0 to
9 it will give us 0 1 2 1 2 3 2 3 4 and
so on and I've written the same thing in
Python and you can see that this is
actually a lot less code I wrote it in
the same formulation as the itertools
version where I'm just combining these
big building blocks and this is written
fairly naively so I haven't put any
attention into optimization and when i
run this so i'll show you if i run this
you can see that's what happens when i
run it they both give the same result so
from 0 to from 1 to 10 I get 1 2 3 2 3 4
told us and what's interesting is when I
time this so here at the top we have our
C++ version being timed and here in the
bottom we have our Python version being
times
and you can see the times are actually
fairly close to each other so we have
3.2 seconds total at the top and 3.6
seconds total bottom it is fairly rare
for us to write naive Python code that
runs within an order of magnitude or C++
code it's fairly rare to us now the
reason that it works in this case is
because this is probably i/o bound but
in general there is something to be said
about generators as a tool for time
efficiency it is I don't personally like
this example that much people seem to
really like comparisons between C++ and
Python and I think that this example
that comparing the two directly does in
some cases miss the point but it does
show us that there is something very
interesting happening here however we
can see that the question of memory
efficiency is with time efficiency is
one that is not so easily answered here
I have a prime allottee just a very
simple prime allottee checking written
with written as a generator expression
and all i'm doing is trial division and
when i run it I can you can see that
it's 2.2 microseconds per loop and then
here I've written it in what you might
consider kind of dumb Python foot format
and you can see it's 1.3 mil
microseconds per loop and what happens
what this tells us is that the process
of creating or instantiating a generator
instance actually overwhelms the time
put into the computation and so this is
not really always the most efficient
mechanism by which to solve our code but
I think the most important the most
important thing about generators are the
structural considerations namely
modeling so the first part is stream
data processing a pipeline so you can
see that since each one of these
generators the building blocks it only
works on one tiny piece of data we can
very nicely create a program that
composes these high level building
blocks as just like if any of you've
been in a band you have your guitar
connected to your amplifier connected to
the distortion connected to this
connected to that and each one of those
pieces along the line process only a
slight piece of data then sends it down
the pipeline and we do this very nice
thing very natural using generators but
more importantly I find that generators
kind of free us from a lot of
presumptions that we have namely
presumptions about returns
so here's our Fibonacci example and this
Fibonacci gives us the Fibonacci
sequence is up to some number in a list
and you can see that if I didn't want a
list but I wanted a set or at uppal you
know it'd take me some time to I would
need additional memory equal to the list
and the set that I'm constructing that
have to be a memory at the same time and
I have to put some time into the into
convertible whereas I've write this as a
generator I've made no presumption about
the return type that the user wants and
as a consequence I do say some time and
I'd save a lot of memory because I don't
have to keep both of these structures in
memory at once so i freed myself from
having to presume how the user is going
to use my code similarly I can free
myself this is very important I can free
myself from presumption about return
values so one thing about the Fibonacci
sequence is that when I want to write it
as a function I have to think do I want
all the Fibonacci numbers up to but not
greater than some number N or I want the
first n Fibonacci numbers and this is
something that I have to bake into the
way that i write this problem and if i
wanted both if I wanted my function be
able to give the first five Fibonacci
numbers or the first Fibonacci numbers
not including or sorry not greater than
five I would have to add in a lot of
really crazy modalities whereas in the
generator formulation I can use these
pieces from itertools in order to write
my generator with no presumption about
how you're going to use it and then use
these building blocks from itertools to
then pull out the values that I want so
instead of having to write two versions
of it i can write one version of it that
just gives an infinite stream and i can
slice and dice that infinite stream as I
desire using take while or even I slice
additionally i can remove from i can
remove from consideration some
presumption about how the values will be
used so here i have this same example
with a sleep put into it and you can see
if i only want the first value in the
functional example i still have to incur
the sleep because i have to encourage
the entire computation whereas in the
second example if i only want the first
value I'll get the first value and i
don't have to incur the sleep because i
don't want any values beyond the first
and this is something that's very
important because in a lot of cases you
know I've seen modeling's of trading
books and they contain millions and
millions of deals and you want to load
up only some subset of the deals in
order to provide produce some analysis
and in one case this
written as a function and so load all
the deals and run out of memory and I
couldn't even load the five deals that I
wanted out of the book of hundreds of
thousands of them because it tried to
load them all up eagerly at once and ran
out of memory whereas in the generator
example I make no presumption about what
you want to use I say i'm just going to
provide you an infinite sequence of
these so i'm gonna provide you all of
them and you get to choose from the
outset how you want to slice and dice is
that how you want to pull which of the
computations you want to perform so i
don't have time to go into this but this
is one example of where this can be used
very nicely in practice so business date
calculations this is something that
every large system ends up writing
itself which is some mechanism by which
to calculate what's today plus two
business days according to some holiday
calendar and this holiday calendar is
usually stored in some SQL database and
when you write this as and people right
this very every time I've seen this
written is been written in some non
closed form format with big while loop
and at end up being a whole mess and
there was a presumption about how you
wanted to use these business days so if
you wanted to get the first five
business days in some particular fashion
or if you wanted to get the next five
business days you may be incurring a lot
of redundant calculation so here's an
example of one way that you can
formulate this as an infinite sequence
of holidays or an infinite sequence of
business days and use the formulations
that generators give you in order to
very nicely from the outside slice and
dice and determine which of these
computations or which which costs of
computations you want to incur
additionally knobs buttons of modalities
so here's a really interesting example
which is a lot of functions we've seen
in large libraries a lot of functions
start to accrue all these knobs and
these modalities and these little pieces
on the end so they end up getting these
very long parameter lists and what
generators allow you to do is to encode
some of these problems very very nicely
very succinctly and very generically so
here's an example of one where I've
implemented so here we have this nasty
little pumped thing where I've
implemented a co routine called
predicate that just takes values out of
something until some predicate is hit
and I've implemented this guy greedy
which is just a combination of pieces
from itertools which implements a greedy
algorithm
and if you think about it the greedy
algorithm is just you have some trace of
information and you pull as many of
these out of here until you hit some
predicate and then you move on to the
next piece of information in Poland and
we can actually use this to solve two
very different problems without changing
that fundamental library code the first
problem we can solve is change
calculation so here you have changed
roars with infinite numbers of
denominations for each one of the each
one of the dominations and currency that
you have and you just pull them until
you hit some predicate which says the
next coin that you take will take you
over the number you go to the next door
and so forth and so on similarly in the
user code so notice there's no there's
no additional modes or not that I had to
add to the library code only the user
code actually drives the use of this and
here i have another example where i'm
solving a very different problem which
is roman numerals to or sorry western
dates to roman numeral dates using the
exact same piece of code where I've just
changed or I just fed into it a
different set of data which is I'm
mapping between Roman numerals and
Arabic numerals so very very interesting
so I want to talk about the showcase I
don't have a lot of time but I run this
meetup group and one of the things that
we do is we like to give away a lot of
prizes because we get a lot of books
from Pearson and O'Reilly and I remember
when I was young that I used to watch
the price is right and the price is
right is a show that exists throughout
the world this is the American prices
right there's actually a price is right
in Great Britain as well that's been on
the air since the 80s and it turns out I
speak Chinese and it turns out there's
also a Chinese prices right as well so
the price is right is probably one of
the most popular game shows in the world
and there's one game called a showcase
showdown which is a giant wheel and they
spin it and this determines whether you
get to is to show up for the showdown
later on in the show and so we wanted to
write some code to give away live some
of these prices and this is something
that hopefully we'll be able to do in
the afternoon today and what I wanted to
do is I wanted to write a wheel I wanted
the note i wanted to number i wanted to
count people off and I wanted the
numbers to show up on the screen I
wanted them to slow down because when
you jump up and pull that we little slow
down as it gets towards the end and
build up the tension so I wanted to do
that and I did this by implementing this
just with some pieces of inner tools
doing sleeps to slow things down but
then I thought I want to make this a
little Wilder because sometimes with the
price is right the wheel will go down to
one dollar which if you get twice you
get 25 thousand dollars and a little
flipper will push it back and then we'll
go backwards and I thought how could I
model a wheel that could also go
backwards and the first thing that I
reached for was object orientation but
you could think that if I would write
this an object orientated fashion it
would end up being really it would it
would seem very naturalistic but it
would end up being kind of weird I'd
have like a spin method and have this
method with that method how can I use
generators to model this and how can I
use it to model it more simply well I
could create a generator called wheel
that very abstractly take some input and
just runs over the data so if I give it
a list of numbers from one to three
you'll do one two three one two three
one two three ad infinitum and I can
give it a direction as well so I can
tell it one two three and then go
backwards but the interesting thing
about this because it's so simple is
that I can test this very easily far
more easily than I can test the object
orientated solution because the object
orientation solution would have embedded
in it all of this state and all these
modalities whereas this is lacking in a
lot of modalities and has no state so i
could just test in a very simple test we
love one two three does it give me
numbers results I have that as a test
later down here you can see I can test
it i can just make sure that the numbers
come out in the director night you know
if i do backwards then come out
backwards and so forth and so on
similarly i can create another generator
called spin and all this does is it
takes my wheel and just spins it given
some function saying how fast it needs
to spin and so here I've given a
transition function that says okay it
slows down according to this rate and I
can also test that velocity function and
this just gives me the velocities which
should spin so unlike the object
orientated fashion would have to test in
some weird fashion would have to set up
some unit test and I have to mock this
and mock that here I just have some
function that gives me the velocities
and all I have to do is make sure that
for the wheel to stop it goes from some
high speed down to some low speed and
stops and you can see here this one
actually goes to a negative speed so it
actually will go backwards and putting
these together I end up with something
that looks like this doesn't show up
very nicely night Python note because I
Python notebook won't show each one of
the initial ones but in the end I end up
with a very interesting solution for
a spinning wheel that's built a very
fundamental building blocks that I could
reuse throughout my code that make no
presumptions about how they're being
used where it's not the library author
that's dictating things but the user of
the code that is able to make use of
this as they see fit where i can i can
add in an enormous number of ways to use
this and the enormous ability from the
outside to control this with very little
code so i want to show you this kind
practice you can see we made we may do
this later today this one here so here
we go and we did this in ncurses so
it'll actually slow down I don't know if
it'll go backwards but you can see it'll
spin and as time goes on it will
actually slow down your heart will start
pumping to see are you the one who's
guys should gonna win the book and and
sometimes I love it when it goes
backwards because somebody's like yeah I
got the book and then it goes up to the
next name and they're very disappointed
and I love to see the look of
disappointment on people's faces so so
so so what this tells us is that
generators are not just some feature
that's added in they're not just some
feature that we can look like decorators
we can look at we could say they're very
interesting but they're just a feature
that was added in that allows us to
remove some boilerplate generators are a
way that we can fundamentally rican
sexualize how we write our code it
allows us to encode lazy computations
and it allows us to very fundamentally
change how our functions look to be able
to write some very abstract very
reusable very non presumptuous blocks of
code code where for example in this
wheel you could add in any velocity
function any transition function and you
could have the wheel move in any
direction however you choose and all of
that is controllable from the outside
it's not you come to me and say could
you add this additional parameter to the
code because I wanted to move in this
direction I want to do this instead I'm
providing you with such such basic
structures that not only are they easily
testable but you can use them in
whatever fashion that you want so that's
the generator showcase showdown
hopefully we'll be able to do a little
bit live coding before the Lightning
talks to give away some of the O'Reilly
books but I hope you enjoyed that and my
name is James pal